mais moi j'avais le droit parce que ma
femme et moi qui le portent pas donc
mais pas de problème et si je laissais
de le porter à l'envi empêcher nous nous
plaignons mon droit
donc je crois pas parce que tu encore
augmenté partout où tu voudras qui
voudraient aujourd'hui comment tout à
lui faire que ça serait constitué nous
on pense que non on a fait des
évaluations et oliver zaugg qui ajuste
de l'alien ancien juge de la cour
suprême qui s'applique à de la retenue
et nous a aussi appuyé en ce sens il ya
beaucoup d'investissement de professions
du droit de se moquer consignes et puis
on dit que c'est le char pas le compte
les droits d'accès rtc faisant ils
devisent une ces postes que l'on a
entendu mais la victime retrouvée oui je
sais mais y'a d'autres d'autres juristes
qui ont dit le contraire
alors il ya des opinions et partager ces
tests mais mais je vous dis que c'est
important de regarder la donne non
seulement ce que ça peut faire au point
de vue moteur donc à court terme et à
long terme nous et vous voulez renforcer
la langue française nous y amener du
monde ma grève et ces gens là si le
mieux ce renvoi et c'est des gens qui
travaillent fort et je pense qu'on est
prêt respecter leurs aînés très
respectueux des gens mais tant pis j'ai
le droit de s'exprimer à ce moment là on
a prêché la pâleur mais trouvait depuis
le départ de la charme tous les paquets
on utiliser les québécois je ne voudrais
pas que les gens pourtant notre entité
gares de quoi parler contre les
musulmans
madame louise
les maisons doit la vie qu'à lévis
qu'elle avait été circoncis studio
pourtant le viol c'est un droit c'est un
crime grave contre avérée non seulement
contre afin de mettre le monde en six
essais de mois comparé une pratique
traditionnelle dans le feutre que c'est
violent c'est carrément coupable a
tellement babel
elle a écrit ça dans le passé où elle a
laissé un policier à quoi elle adhère
c'est notre grande partie je m'en vais
représenter la population
ce à quoi elle adhère s'émeut programme
et notre programme est très respectueux
de toutes les religions du monde alors
je te souhaite bonne chance ratée avec
le 30 mai les mêmes sans fin